writer lecturer and philosopher Ralph
Waldo Emerson is regarded as one of the
primary founders of American literature
and can be credited with inspiring many
prolific writers writing styles cultural
perspectives and philosophical movements
Emerson was born in 1803 in Boston
Massachusetts to ruth Haskins and
William Emerson his father being a
Christian minister descending from a
lineage of previous ministers during his
adolescence Emerson studied at Harvard
University and following graduation he
would go on to teach at his brother's
school for young women after several
years of teaching he would then enroll
into Divinity School at Harvard to train
to become a pastor in 1829 he was
ordained in a Boston's second church and
would spend the following three years or
so as a pastor during this time however
Emerson would find an increasing sense
of detachment and disagreement with
traditional religious practices in ways
of thinking specifically he found that
contemporary Christianity encountered
and sedated the very essence of human
spirituality that it was supposed to
inspire around three years after
becoming a pastor and after about one
year following his first wife's young
death of tuberculosis
Emerson resigned from the church I have
sometimes thought that in order to be a
good minister it was necessary to leave
the ministry Emerson wrote in his
journal following his stint as a pastor
Emerson spent the next two years writing
and publishing his first major essays
while developing a career as a public
lecturer Emerson would make his first
significant mark on the public with his
controversial lectures that suggested
the value of separating from commonly
withheld religious ideas and traditions
and in place argued for infusing new
independent forward thinking that relied
on the self or divine experience and
understanding during the following
decades
Emerson continued giving lectures and
producing several major influential
works of literature he would soon become
recognized as one of the mid 19th
century leading writers and thinkers
inspiring individuals like Henry David
Thoreau Friedrich Nietzsche Walt Whitman
Emily Dickinson and innumerable others
as well as being the key figure and
helping give way to new cultural
perspectives and philosophical movements
especially the philosophy known as
transcendentalism which Emerson is
regarded as the father of Emerson's
philosophy can perhaps be best explained
in two of his most famous essays nature
publish
in 1836 and self-reliance published in
1841 between these two works
Emerson primarily discusses man and
nature being a unified singular whole
the value of trusting one's own
intuition and sense of reality and the
realization and forthright expression of
one's unique greatness and truth
more specifically Emerson posed that all
of nature is an expression and
permeation of one metaphysical essence
of the universe or God and that we are
all both the expressions and Express
Earth of this singular oneness nature in
its ministry to man Emerson wrote is not
only the material but is also the
process and the result in this there's
no separation between humanity and
nature where humanity can will itself on
to nature nor nature on to humanity but
rather everything is essentially nature
interacting with nature standing on the
bare ground my head bathed by the blithe
air and uplifted into infinite space all
mean egotism vanishes I become a
transparent eyeball
I am nothing I see all the currents of
the universal being circulate through me
I am part or particle of God Emerson
wrote for Emerson the distinction
between the trees the bugs the dirt the
stars and everything else is all but a
phenomenal distinction not necessarily a
real one rather he believed that God is
one thing found in everything and
through everything every object every
individual and every particle of
existence in the eternal now as such for
Emerson the transcendent spiritual
experience is not found from any outward
previous or future source but within the
individual in any given moment moments
were one's own mind illuminates the
common features of their surroundings
with potency beauty and
interconnectedness alongside this
Emerson also asserted that nature is in
a constant state of flux and that we
must live in coordination with its
process trusting our own intuition and
flowing with the changing self in order
to do this he argued that we must not
hold ourselves to ideas beliefs or
traditions of the past include
our own rather Emerson suggested that
our state is subject to change and
consequently we might feel or think one
way today in the opposing way tomorrow
instead of fighting this however Emerson
argued that we must lean into it
no man he wrote can antedate his
experience or guess what faculty or
feeling a new object shall unlock any
more than he can draw today the face of
a person whom he shall see tomorrow for
the first time in other words no one can
know what life might be like tomorrow
nor would such life may cause one to
think or feel however one must move with
it and live according to the present now
out of this emerges what is perhaps
Emerson's most popular concept known as
self-reliance Emerson argued that we
often neglect to ever realize the unique
perspective and greatness that comes
from our particular culmination of
experiences and States not because we
don't have access to such greatness but
because we're often held back and pulled
away from it by others and systems of
convention for Emerson great artists
thinkers writers and so on aren't
necessarily great merely because they
possess access to any higher exclusive
source of information or being but
because they are willing to address and
express candidly what they feel in any
given moment of life despite how it
might reflect on the standard norm and
in doing so they reveal not only their
unique take on the world but also the
thoughts and sensations hidden within a
great many others who feel the same
arguably great artists and writers
aren't merely popular because they say
something no one is thought of or
experienced before but because they say
something that most of us have but
weren't sure if we were right to do so
Emerson believed that for the sake of
one's work and sense of self the
individual must rely on themselves alone
and recognize that what they feel and
think is real and legitimate in a very
cartesian idea if we can know anything
at all it is merely that we exist and if
we can suppose anything at all it is
merely our own experience this does not
disparage our sympathy for others others
ideas nor a connection with the natural
world but rather it serves to prevent
the disparagement of our self amidst at
all it serves to promote trust in our
own unique interpretations and
experiences and encourages us to express
their individual merit
in slight contrast to Emerson it appears
reasonable to also argue that perhaps
there are variations in the resources
and conditions of each individual and
thus one's ability to trust and/or
express themselves is not always equal
if nature and human is a unified whole
carried out through a process of self
fulfilling change is it not also
possible that one's own ability to
defend and tap into themselves is part
of a natural order and fluctuation
beyond one's will of course this simply
serves to beg the question that if we
were all transparent eyeballs how much
say do we have and how much vision we
have perhaps Emerson's concept of
self-reliance can still exist in harmony
with this question perhaps so long as
one authentically stands in their own
position of confusion and limitation
they've still remained in accordance
with their own relative truth and
greatness and the notion of
self-reliance hold steady of course like
all philosophies and philosophers
Emerson's ideas in general aren't
without flaws or counter arguments but
it is the fault of our rhetoric that we
cannot strongly state one fact without
seeming to Balai some other I hold our
actual knowledge very cheap Emerson
wrote with this Emerson himself
suggested that he never spoke with any
objective certainty or final truth
regarding what he thought for this and
other reasons unmentioned self-reliance
and individuality is not easy it does
not simply come from agreeing with
poetic prose to know and trust one's
self in the face of consistent change
confusion in a world that works to
consolidate everyone is perhaps one of
the hardest things anyone can do and
furthermore not always but certainly
some of the time it comes with the risk
of some amount of separation from the
common populace and conventional norms
however perhaps the question one must
ask here is if all we can know in
experience is our self how can any life
be lived fully if one denies themselves
before even trying if we hide or hinder
ourselves out of the fear of rejection
from others are we not in essence
rejecting our own self first
the only person we truly in inescapably
have to live with
Emerson's work is a reinforcement and
reminder of the importance of combating
this to attempt to live in the spirit of
individuality self honesty and
authenticity in each moment and in each
context of life to raise the sail of
one's own ship using the unknowable
force of the wind while steering as best
we can always moving forward finding
beauty in the vastness that surrounds us
and creating ourselves anew
[Music]
you